my colleague from the nfl media group
ian rappaport back here on the show how
are you doing ian
i'm great how you doing i'm hanging in
there so andrew branch says this goes
down to a showdown
that uh packer's not trading him and
rogers doesn't want to show up he could
stay at home
do you see that uh in your crystal ball
that you don't have
right now did we ignore jeopardy what
about the jeopardy factor
well i mean they're gonna have to chew
i'm hearing they're choosing their uh
their eventual
uh choice very shortly uh really you
know did i get it
uh you did not i have not heard your
name floated ian i have not
i've heard ken jennings a little bit
more than you let's put it that way
that's okay which one is that is that
the producer who's trying to get to be
the host
wow hollywood insider and
the dirty laundry oh my god no that's
fact isn't it i mean that's not
that's isn't that what's happening
listen ian i don't
i don't know what you're talking about i
mean uh if you're reading the same blogs
i am i don't know but uh
yeah didn't his like executive producer
put himself in as the
tryout host he did in fact well no no no
he he said that somebody
uh got coveted and that's why he tried
out and uh and he was well received
by people like and magazines and stuff
like that wow but ken jennings is the
former
you know he's the former jeopardy
champion that uh is rumored to be the
front runner for the job as well but we
also haven't seen
but who knew all i know is that i don't
know if that's a reason why aaron would
retire
is what i'm saying it's not a sure-fire
thing
yeah got it um so i i see it a little
differently from andrew brandt i mean
i no one has told me and you know i say
this
i i do not have all the information i
have not talked to everyone involved i
have not talked to specifically aaron
rodgers
so i don't know this for a fact but no
one has told me that rogers is
definitely not coming to camp
no one has told me he's never playing
for the packers again unless
this or this happens unless they trade
him i mean he's had
opportunities to say publicly and to
send messages privately that he wants to
be traded
um i have not heard that so to me it's
more of can this issue get solved before
training camp rather than
a stare down like there have been
in-person meetings as we know in
california in green bay
there have been contract negotiations
there's been an offer from the packers
obviously it is not something
aaron rodgers has accepted and you know
you don't always accept the first offer
as everybody knows
but to me it's more of issue that needs
to be solved
rather than a stare down and it's just
so interesting to hear
you know some of aaron rodgers friends
including one who works in our network
james jones
talk about how it's fixable that is what
i believe too
um but that doesn't mean it's going to
happen
well the question is is uh when does
something like that happen in the
meantime jordan love apparently had a
very good day
today and yes and but that's what i
think
but all of that swell you know look the
bottom line is you know
he's gonna have to have a ton of good
days just to even get ready for the new
orleans saints and
i mean cameron jordan is just licking
his chops literally right now i mean if
we stop talking we could probably hear
it wherever cam jordan is
appearing and i've got malcolm jenkins
on tomorrow's show and
that may or may not come up as a
conversation piece
but um you know the the the ultimate
thing is that that kind of does help
green bay right now that the kid's
getting his reps and getting his sea
legs under him and
a little bit going on and working a
little bit of a lather up that is
helpful
to green bay today i mean i hate to say
this
because like we all have spent you know
the last couple weeks wondering if
rogers is going to show up to mini camp
and then
he doesn't show up and then we all have
you know we send tom pelicero my
esteemed colleagues green bay to talk
about rogers just not being there and
all this is
treated as something that is very
important i'm not sure i see a downside
for anyone with roger's not being there
except maybe that he has
to find but sort of who cares um it's
good that jordan loves gets the reps
it's nice for the packers to see what
they have
i've talked to plenty of people who like
what jordan love
did last year thought it's going fine
but have literally no idea how good of a
quarterback he's going to be because he
hasn't played in games and he hasn't
gotten the reps
nobody knows just like nobody knew what
kind of quarterback aaron rodgers was
going to be when he was in his second
year so
more reps for jordan love is good roger
staying out of harm's way is good
we still need to get this whole thing
fixed but i don't really get any
negative
anything from roger's not doing a mini
camp at all all right ian rappaport here
on the rich eisen show how did the
titans wind up with julio
walk me through what you know and what
uh what it can
potentially inform uh the titans uh
preparedness to have a guy
who might want a new contract sooner
rather than later
at this position uh first of all as far
as the new contract
you know i'm not saying it's not true
but i have not heard that he's going to
be asking for one after this year either
i mean i guess anything is possible but
you know a 33 year old receiver
two years left on his contract asking
for a new deal
when the deal at the time was maybe the
i don't need like maybe the best
contract i've ever seen i mean joey goes
is pretty great there's been a couple
other good ones but like
one of the best contracts in nfl history
like i i have my doubts on whether or
not i was going to be looking for a new
deal but
so before the draft so here's i'll walk
you through quick
quickly to the timeline late february
julio jones asked to be traded the
falcons
agreed to consider it you get through
free agency
not much happens um and then before the
draft which sometimes is when these
sorts of trades can happen
teams start calling we have teams like
you know the ravens are one of them and
then they realized the contract wasn't
something they wanted they were out and
then they drafted a couple receivers so
they were out you had the rams you had
the 49ers
a couple others maybe the patriots
inquired but they didn't feel like
there's much going there
there was some teams that were
interested and then when the draft
happens when they didn't deal by the
draft
the market got smaller because some
teams like the ravens filled their
killed their needs um so this was really
about
to me the tennessee titans all along
because they were as far as i could tell
the only team that offered it to
so they went a couple weeks without
speaking and the market didn't get
better
so basically before beta camp the
falcons were like all right we're gonna
do this
it's probably gonna be tennessee because
they have easily the best offer we need
a little more to do it right now
so if we can get a second plus
you know essentially a fifth round pick
which is a four for six swap
will do it and that the titans up their
ante and
you know he was he's now a member of the
tennessee titans but to me they were
always kind of a front runner
so i the question is is you know what
why didn't other teams do it
you know i i i understand he's 32 and he
didn't you know he didn't play nine
games last year but i mean this is a
hall of fame talent i mean
we've seen receivers perform well after
the age of 30 before i mean i i know
that they're they're fewer and further
between than
than quarterbacks at that position or
maybe even pass rushers but i mean
god doesn't look like he's he's you know
not eating right i i it's kind of a head
start when he played last year he was
very good
right yeah and um you know
i think the the biggest symbol of the
whole problem with this trade market is
literally on the titan
aj brown aj brown was a second rounder
he is awesome he is going to be
extremely
well paid i would say easily one of the
best receivers in the nfl
and the possibility right of getting a
player like aj brown
or dk metcalf for instance in the second
round
um and having him on a very cheap
contract for four years is extremely
enticing
so people general managers don't want to
give up
a potential cheap asset for a very
expensive asset who's aging
and so that's why like the trade market
for these veterans
is never quite what you think like to me
if julio jones plays
two years and is good then it's a great
trade for the titans i mean i guess if
he plays one year and is really good
and it's probably a trade they're fine
with anyway but giving up cheap labor is
something that ethel teams do not really
want to do
ian rappaport here on the rich eisen
show and julio jones uh was
becoming a conversation leading up to
the draft with uh
talk about the the cap hamstrung falcons
and obviously
his uh you know uh speakerphone
appearance on fs1 sent it in a totally
different orbit we're obsessed with
rogers quite a bit and we used to be
with russell wilson which is
old news according to pete carroll as he
said right here on this show
uh desean watson uh and his
whereabouts and story is i mean
just to say it's quiet is not even um
a proper statement what is the scope on
that are you hearing anything
on that side i do appreciate that kareem
jackson went on a podcast with
who is that one of his former teammates
we got to leave this podcast anyway
went on podcast and said that deshaun
watson told him
that denver's ray wants to be check with
some people it's not really true
it's what's happening with desean watson
is everyone is recruiting really
everyone across the nfl is doing hey man
you should come join us
and it sounds like watson is pretty open
like yeah hey it'd be great app would
love it yep we'll see what happens
open to it and you know kareem jackson
probably embellished that conversation a
little bit for the pod
and uh you know here we are but you know
i would say denver is probably one of
his
one of many options towards sean watson
and you talk about the quiet
the reason it's quiet is just because
there's nothing going on there's been no
settlement
despite i would say significant
settlement talks
there's been nothing agreed to and we've
seen the lawyers go back and forth on
that
there's still teams interested in
trading in but it hasn't happened
yet and i haven't gotten the sense
texans have engaged with anyone at all
yet
um so we're just literally nowhere
and you know minicamp is next week
uh assuming they have it and we'll see
what happens there
yeah there are some teams that i guess
are are canceling their
mandatory mini camps and that i i heard
the texans are considering that
well i read that from john mclean in
houston it's kind of
bizarre that a team that you know uh
finished so poorly
and is uh at such a square one that they
would forfeit reps and things of that
nature but
when you're saying they were they're
significant they there there were talks
to actually settle this thing
in a manner that would then place it in
front of the commissioner to see how
many games if any
watson would miss um because i'm not
hearing about any criminal charges being
filed against him if that is something
that is
you know warranted i'm not hearing
anything like that
i mean i would imagine if they settle
the criminal stuff will probably go away
because
usually not speaking specifically to
watson but usually
when the uh when the
people agree that both sides agree to
settle usually that means like we're not
going to pursue any other evidence and
the settlement is just what it is so i
would imagine the criminal would go away
if it is settled but it's really about
as the lawyers have explained
in some snipes back and forth to each
other
it seems that busby wants everything to
be private
and desean watson and his legal team do
not
um so i don't i don't know which side
spends but i don't know if anyone is
spending anytime soon
all right and last thing for you ian i'm
just it's so exciting to see in baseball
stadiums
and you know uh hockey arenas and the
nba arenas fans and i know the nfl says
that fans are
expect to be back in full you know uh
in stadiums this fall and the nfl has
basically told coaches that if they did
not get vaccinated by i believe it was
monday
uh the start of training camp they would
not be allowed access to players and any
coaches who are not vaccinated
enjoy coaching from your office this
season and yet players are not held to
the same standard
um you know ron rivera saying today that
the team is nearing 50
in vaccinated players he had a vaccine
expert come to talk to the team
and i believe part of the reason why is
he's got a player in monte sweat who
said today
uh that he's not a fan of the coveted
vaccine until i get more facts
i haven't caught covert yet so i don't
see me treating covet until i actually
get coveted
everybody's entitled to their own
decision which is true
but uh i can at least tell montez that
uh i haven't had a key stick to me yet
um so um my question for you is
why why are players not you know
required to get vaccinated
like the rest of nfl staff best you can
tell and
um and and what what is the the players
association stance
on something like this prior to this
yeah i mean first
you know first of all some of the
numbers from some of the teams are
honestly that's like a little troubling
i don't know what's going to happen uh
if
and you know it's so clear like the nfl
is not going to force players to get
vaccinated and we we haven't seen a ton
of businesses
force their people maybe hospitals are a
little different but force their people
to get back saying you just
you want everyone to do it so you could
be normal right like
you want to get to the threshold where
you can have a normal life and for
players like
that means not being tested every day
that means not having to come in on
christmas day and be tested or just your
off day i mean
you know not having travel restrictions
i mean if you're on the road if you're
vaccinated you can go out to dinner with
your friends if you're not vaccinated
you cannot
you have to wear a mask everywhere i
mean it is highly highly highly
incentivized
for players to get vaccinated and
still plenty of them haven't no no
coaches
i mean you know coaches are obviously a
little older and seemingly more mature
so it is almost impossible to do your
job as a coach
almost impossible if you are not
vaccinated for a player you can do your
job you just
have to wear a mask and it's just it
gets a little bit more difficult so
you know i think the nfl and the nflpa
both are encouraging education and for
players to
make their own decisions you hope
everyone makes the right
decision and everyone can be normal in
the fall but the way it's going
i'm not sure that's going to be the case
ian thanks for the time really
appreciate it
you take care of yourself let's chat uh
let's chat in the next couple weeks
as conditions warrant you take care of
yourself all right
always look forward to it rich take care
you're the best that's uh ian rappaport
at rap sheet
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here